- Good afternoon, I'd
like to welcome everyone
to our Fourth Endeavors
Colloquium this semester.
And it's a glorious day
for several reasons,
not least of which being
that we're around the bend
with the election.
And it's really great to come together
and think about the
meaning and power of art
to guide us through moments like these.
I'm Jacqueline Goldsby I'm chair
of African-American Studies here at Yale.
And I want to point out that
we have two more sessions
to present in this series of discussions.
We've been holding off semester
next Thursday on November
19th, which is a Thursday.
This is a special day.
But on Thursday, November
19th at 11:45 to 1:15,
one of our newest faculty members
in African-American Studies
Professor Phillip Goff
will detail the groundbreaking
work he's been doing
directing the Center for Policing Equity.
And there's a way in
which the center's work
has kind of aptly summed
up in one of its models
doing data science for racial justice.
And Professor Goff will
unpack what that phrase,
that idea means and how his
team has put that principle
into scholarly action
and political activism
around the politics of policing.
So that will be next Thursday.
And then on December 10th,
I believe it is, yes.
Another Thursday from 11:45 to 1:15,
another new colleague
Professor Elizabeth Hinton,
a wonderful, brilliant historian
will team up with a long time ally
of African-American Studies,
Professor Tracy Meares of the Law School.
And they're going to map out
the work that's happening
at the Justice Collaboratory,
which is a research and
policy action center
organized by law school faculty.
So those are the next two events,
and we hope to see all of you there.
The department chose to dedicate
the semester's colloquium series
to issues that would be decisive
to the outcome of the
presidential election and beyond
because we know our work is not done.
Even though the election
went in the direction
I hope most of us want it to go.
But just to review for those of you
who haven't been with us these past weeks,
the challenges of securing voting rights
and theorizing new models of citizenship,
which we got to do with LaTosha Brown,
who directs, co-directs,
co-founded Black Voters Matter
this tremendously still
alive with us as an issue.
The delivery of justice
advancing healthcare
to the formerly incarcerated,
their families and communities
was an amazing discussion
that we held with Emily Wang,
who directs the Center
for Health and Justice
out of the Yale School of Medicine.
And today, again, we're
going to be thinking
about the enduring and
evolving role of art
in making social justice
thinkable and actionable
with our extraordinary panel
who you'll meet in just a minute.
I wanna thank our co-sponsor
the Center for Study of Race, Indigeneity,
and Transnational Migration
who's been co-sponsoring
these events with us
and the Director of RITM
Professor Steve Pitti
and its Associate Director Matthew Tanico
have been extraordinary colleagues
with us to make all of this come together.
I wanna thank them.
I also wanna thank our staff, Vanessa Epps
who's been incredibly diligent
of just stepping into
the work, publicizing
and getting these Zoom links out
for all of us to congregate here together.
I wanna thank her for that work.
And Emmanuel Bissell,
who's here with us today
managing of the Zoom room to make sure
that all the connections
work the way they should.
I wanna thank them both
for their support of this initiative.
And now I wanna turn it over
to my colleague, Professor
Crystal Feimster,
who's done a brilliant
job organizing the series
and she'll introduce today's panel.
- Thank you, Jackie.
And I also wanna add my gratitude
to both Vanessa and Emmanuel
for all their support
and making this happen and working with me
and just making sure
everything runs smoothly.
(indistinct) is particularly Vanessa.
I haven't said this,
but helping to design the beautiful flyers
that we have for this series.
Vanessa put a lot of work into that
and I think they're really beautiful.
So I want to just give her a shout out
for her work on that front.
But also want to thank all
of you for being here today.
I know like myself and
many others retired,
but I think there is joy
and much to celebrate.
I know that I been inspired
in the last couple of days
in way that I haven't been
able to find inspiration
in a while.
And I think that part of our celebration,
I feel like this work,
these artists that are with us today
are gonna inspire us
with not just their words and their art,
but with their presence and remind us that
the ways in which we can find beauty
and joy in the struggle.
So I am so grateful that they
are gonna be with us today
and holding this space for us.
Before I introduce them,
I wanna remind folks about the format.
We will allow our participants engage
in a robust and conversation
for about 45 minutes.
Around four o'clock,
I will sort of give them the nod
to go ahead and start
opening up for questions.
We take the questions in the chat.
Ideally, we would love for you
to send those questions,
comments to Claudia Rankine
in the private chat,
and she will sort through the questions
and really present them
our two gifted artists,
scholars, intellectuals
to respond to.
I'll ask that you do that
and make sure you keep your mikes on mute
throughout the conversation.
And on that note, I have the great honor
of introducing three wonderful
scholars and artists.
I wanna begin with my
colleague Claudia Rankine.
She is the author of five books of poetry,
including "Citizen" and "American lyric",
and "Don't Let Me Be Lonely",
three plays, including
"Help" and "The White Card",
her recent collection of essays
was just published by Graywolf Press
in 2020 titled "Just Us"
and "American Conversation".
And in 2016, Rankine co-founded
the Racial Imaginary Institute
and among her numerous awards and honors
Rankine is the recipient
of the Bobbitt National Prize for Poetry,
the Poets and Writers
Jackson Poetry Prize,
and a Fellowships from
the Guggenheim Foundation
and the MacArthur Foundation
and the National Endowment of
the Arts to just name a few.
And we're really lucky and honored
to have her leading
this conversation today.
We also have Reginald Dwayne Betts,
one of a friend and a colleague
and a co-parent in this
community that we call New Haven.
So it's a real treat to
have him in Athenaeum
in conversation with us today.
He's a renowned and published
poet speaker and leader
in public defense and advocacy.
Betts is the recipient of numerous awards,
including the 2018 Guggenheim Fellowship
and the New American Fellowship.
Betts' writing has been
featured in the New York Times,
The New Yorker and the Washington Post.
Betts is currently leading
The Million Book Projects
with my colleague, Elizabeth Hinton
and colleagues over in the law school,
under Tracy Meares' leadership over there,
and then initiative which aims
to transform the role of
literature and libraries
in the lives of people in prison
is in the making.
They're doing that work now.
And finally, I wanna
introduce Titus Kaphar,
also a friend and a member
of this New Haven Community
that we're really lucky to have him here.
He's an artist whose painting sculptures
and installations examine
the history of representation
by transforming it styles and mediums
with formal innovations to
emphasize the physicality
and the dimensionality of the canvas
and materials themselves.
Kaphar received an MFA
from the Yale school of Art
and as a distinguished recipient
of numerous prizes and awards,
including a 2014 Gwendolyn Knight
and Jacob Lawrence Fellowship
and 2018 art for Justice Fund grant,
and the 2018 Rappaport Prize.
Kaphar is painting Analogous Colors 2020.
It was featured on the cover
of the June 15th, 2020
issue of Time Magazine,
which included a report
on the protest sparked
by George Floyd's killing at the
hands of Minneapolis police.
Kaphar's work is included
in the collections
of the Museum of Modern Art,
of course, the Yale University Art Gallery
among many others.
Kaphar has two forthcoming exhibits,
and one of them actually
might be open now in New York,
but he can talk about
that, and in Belgium.
And on that note,
I'm gonna turn it over to Dwayne
who is going to share some images with us
so that we can all be on the same page.
- Cool, yeah, how's everybody doing?
Oh this is Zoom y'all
can't even talk back to me.
I'ma share my screen
and then will walk you
through a few images
and then we will start the conversation.
Thank everybody for coming though.
So what you see here is
I'm just gonna walk through
some of the pieces
that went to Pleading Freedom Exhibit.
So this is one of Titus's pieces,
and really I'm just gonna
show you the images.
I'm not going to try to
explain it or talk about them.
I'm just gonna run through them.
And those are the pieces.
- Thanks Dwayne, hello
everyone, good afternoon.
It's I was up on a rock today.
It's a beautiful day.
So it's nice to spend
the afternoon with you.
And I bring up being on the rock
because I went on a walk the other day
and I was telling someone
that I was working with
that I was going to talk
to Dwayne and Titus today.
And they said, Oh, Dwayne and Titus,
they met at St. Thomas.
I don't even know if this is true,
but the story I got was that
because their children
went to the same school
they became friends.
Is this at all true either of you?
- I can't see Titus, but no it's not true.
- It's not true.
- It's okay though.
Everybody has to have a
mythology created about them,
so we could just say that.
- Now I met them.
- How you met them.
I liked that story
because I liked the fact
that it was the generations
that your kids were bringing together.
You two great guys
and amazing artists in the world.
But okay, it's not true.
So there it goes.
I'm gonna have to go back to that person
and ask them where they got that from.
The Pleading Freedoms Exhibit,
which is the sort of
catalyst for this talk
is a talk that I thought we could rename
this discussion in this way,
that our conversation
is going to be about racials, redactions
and other critical creative
collaborations and endeavors
by the both of you.
I wanted to begin by
thinking about a racial.
There are many ways to enter into that,
and it's been a very sort of hot topic
because we've had in
circulation a lot of videos
around black death and black suffering.
And so I was really
interested in beginning
with the considerations of how each of you
sort of walk the line
between artists and activists
or writer and activist relative
to the creation of work.
And then the second part
of that question would be,
how does the act of engaging
either racial or redactor
from archival materials
play into the practice?
- Yeah, that's an interesting question.
I wonder about the first piece
you had on the Times Magazine cover Titus
'cause I sort of feel like,
at least for me,
it was a bit of a reluctance
actually to try to make my art
immediately reflect in the moment
to try to speak to the immediate moment.
That concerns that were on my mind
as a citizen in this country.
And I remember the actually,
you had Aragon, you had Michael Brown,
and you just had his wave,
and I'll just speak to
the two specific poems
and how they came about.
And they came about,
as first, I was resistant
trying to be the poet
that writes about the
things happening right now,
'cause in some ways you end up getting
a slogan instead of a poem.
And I was writing verses at Arigna
and my full intent was to try to engage
with this question of violence
and how violence was working
within our country and
within our communities
and specifically within
the world of incarceration.
And I understood it and my friends
and I just remember driving
to Rutgers for a talk.
And when I came back,
I think somebody got
acquitted on the way back
and we got awarded acquittal or something.
And it was just in that moment
that I ended up just having to change
one of the poems that I written,
I had to rethink it
and really seriously
take into considerations
what it was that I was trying to say.
And I know I had one line in it,
I sort of framed a conversation,
but I knew I had one line in it.
"If somebody is throwing a trash can
"through Sal's window,
calling that revolution
"while the body still roll off
the blocks into the prisons
"and into the graveyards."
And so for me, the
whole process was an act
of like a reluctance of
reluctance of reluctance
until so much a resistant
a moment forced me
into the moment and allowed me, I think,
to get into the moment in a different way.
And to me, race poem that
I wrote was the same.
It was sorta like,
I'm not writing a poem about this.
I'm not gonna write a poem about
the police murder into my race
until I told a friend to write a poem
about something they
would never read in public
and at the law school to get this wall
where everybody could talk.
And like I wrote this poem
and I was so mad at the discussions
that were going on around
what was happening.
I have wrote the poem a few weeks ago
and I was never gonna show anybody.
And then I just posted it
to the entire law school
as if that's how you publish a poem.
And I thought that is
how you publish a poem.
When you write a piece
and you want the community where you live
to hear everything that you got to say.
ANd the poem was kind of raw, actually,
I hadn't even really
worked on it too much.
It was just there.
And it was the same thing.
How do you...
And in fact, I wrote that
to speak about St. T's,
I was really thinking about
what it meant to drive my kids to school
in a really privileged school
and a really privileged place.
And I was thinking about
how we got a whole...
We got far too many black folks
who own a kind of suffering
and fear that their lives don't embody.
And I felt it was something
grotesque about it.
I still think there's
something grotesque about that.
And it's like, how do I work
my way through these issues
while acknowledging that it
is a fair amount of privilege
that I carry every day into the world.
And so part of that poem was
me trying to confront that
and trying to say, you
know, despite the privilege,
I'm still a black man
driving his two children,
his two black sons to school
and the death of the
murder of a 12 year old.
This was playing a repeat in my head.
So anyway, these poems for
me come out of a reluctance
and I'm not really an
activist in any kind of way.
I try to get people I know how to prison.
I've decided that I just need
to simplify my own terms.
And so I'm in no way an activist really.
I just try to get people
I know how to prison.
- Titus before you go,
don't answer the question.
I just wanna follow up
with Dwayne on one thing.
When you have written so
much about your own life
as somebody who...
Your last book is called "Felon".
So in some ways Dwayne
aren't you turning yourself
into a metaphor of the
system of mass incarceration
so that the subject of your work
becomes not, it's both personal
and public at the same time,
and as personal as you get.
The piece about in the Times
where you bring up your mother's story
as well as a rape victim.
It seems to me that this idea
that you're reluctant
to move into the realm
of the devastated and
victimize black person
within our society might be useful for you
in the creation of things,
but it's not necessarily true
in terms of where you're going
in terms of your subject.
- It depends 'cause it took me
10 years to write that piece
that I just published in the Times.
A literal and 10 years to...
And really you could say 15
in terms of knowing my
mother's experience,
and then even beginning to write about it.
And if you go through the trace,
the through line of my work,
you'll find me dealing
with sexual assault a lot.
And you'll find me dealing
with domestic violence a lot.
But that's me taking half steps
to the thing that I
wanted or needed to say.
So I would argue that,
it's like, yes and no.
I would argue that...
And even in the poems I
write in first person a lot,
but part of it is I believe that
I need to figure out a way
how to situate all of it in the lyric ad,
because I think anything
else ends up being me
unwilling to embrace
some of the hardest things I write about
so that when somebody is inflicting pain,
it's always somebody else
that's doing it, it's not me.
So even when you read 'Felon",
it is a fair amount of it that's me,
but it's also a fair amount
of it is written in the
first person is not me.
And most of those poems.
I hope they feel fresh and
I hope they feel immediate,
but a lot of that work has
taken like years to get to.
And some of it is not about me at all.
But what you said that
whole heartedly agree with
is the point is the juxtaposition
out of public and private
to create something that I
feel is like fully political.
But I feel like that work...
I try to honor the work that activists do
and just sort of like acknowledge
that that's not what it is that I do.
And frequently, I'm just
lucky that my work is...
Like this conversation about
Harris and sexual assault
and also getting friends out of prison.
Like fundamentally that piece
is talking about two people
who I can name and I can pull up
a Springshare parole
package that I'm working on
to get them out of prison.
Like that work feels like
it's at a moment right now,
but I've been working on those
cases for five, six years.
I've been working on trying
to get them out of prison
before Virginia brought parole back.
And so it is a way in which
you can read it and think,
Oh man, Dwayne is on point.
He is right in the moment.
And the truth is no,
I'm just lost in the moment
that I got lost in...
When I called Jack somebody
on December 7th, 1996.
- Thank you, what about you Titus?
How do you walk the line
between being an artist
and an activist since
your work speaks directly
as timeless as the pieces are.
They're still historical,
they're still critiquing,
they're still engaged
in many of the vibrant
questions we have now.
- I think one of the things
that Dwayne is getting at is,
and one of the things
I think we're eventually
going to get at is
just this idea that the
political is personal
and the personal political.
I think eventually we're gonna
come around to that somehow.
The piece that Dwayne referred to,
the first painting that was in the Time
was editorialize as something
that was very much about Ferguson,
but Ferguson was a secondary,
it's the B role to the A role
in terms of what the painting is about.
The painting is about
me getting stopped by the
police with my brother.
That's what the painting is about.
The painting is about
my personal experience,
being a Chelsea, I've shared this a lot
where the police officers
stopped me and my brother,
while we were walking down the street
and put us up against
a wall, put guns on us
and accused me of stealing
art out of my own shop.
It's personal, and I think
for me that's the hard part,
I'm like what you were
saying before Dwayne is like,
when at that point in my practice,
actually, that was point in my practice
where my work was no longer private
'cause up until then,
I'm just a dude in the studio making stuff
that nobody really cares about anyway.
I'm just trying to figure out
what's going on in my head.
And then that work came into the world
and all of a sudden I
found myself being public
in a way that anybody who knows me
knows that I'm not like
super comfortable with.
And so I think what
Dwayne may be resisting
is this idea of us as activists symbols.
There's a whole like
symbolism that goes along
with that idea that I'm just
not in no way interested in it.
I'm interested in the work.
I'm interested in justice.
I'm interested in understanding
my role in the world,
but I read too much history
and seeing too much history
to know that...
To be comfortable with the way
in which people wanna put you
on a some kind of a different pedestal
as an activist,
just to wait for you to
slip up and fall down
and then like have some overjoyed
expression when you fall.
The other thing I want to say is like,
no, that story is not true
about (indistinct) but,
and I know Jason Stanley is on the line
who always wants to take credit
for us meeting each other,
but I'm not gonna let you do that.
But what I will say about
this story is our friendship
is rooted in our fatherhood.
I think that Dwayne and I
like our connection is deeper
because we are both black fathers
trying to figure out
how to raise our kids.
And we are raising our kids in realities
so different from the
reality that we grew up in.
Our kids have no
understanding of the struggles
that we went through
when we were their age.
And in some ways we don't
necessarily want them
to fully understand that,
they shouldn't have to go through that.
But I think that that's a fundamental part
of our relationship.
We talk a lot about being dads
and what that means.
Even though that wasn't,
we didn't meet at St. Thomas in that way,
both of our kids go to St. Thomas.
And so it has become
a very important part of our relationship.
- Thank you for that.
I also wanna pick up on this reluctance
around the naming of the
work as in any way activist.
Because I wonder,
and I wonder this from
my own personal position,
there has been a tendency to name work
that is done by black
people as political work.
And that has been out there as a way
to denigrate the work in an odd way.
Both is flattering and saying that,
oh, you're involved in what's going on,
you're on the cutting edge
of politics in America.
But on the other way,
it's a way of saying it's not white work,
it's not transcendent work,
it's not work that is able
to really address the human condition
and how all of us are one thing
and blah blah blah blah blah
as if there is a lack of
investment in whiteness
in the work of white people.
Often I see artists
who are of color
running away from that way
of talking about their work.
And I wonder how much we think about,
or fear the idea that people will use it
as a redactive measure around your work,
whether it's the writing or the paintings.
- Yeah, I think the first,
I just re-read "Please
Don't Let Me Be Lonely"
a few months ago.
And I'm like,
why don't I keep editing please.
- Put you put please, it's a song.
- It is a song.
It may be-
- You read that book and?
- And what I was thinking is Sean Bell
I'm a do the yellow.
The work is laced with that,
and it's beautiful work and
it's not work of a time,
is work of time.
You go back to it and it
keeps delivering a richness.
If somebody's pickup "Citizen", they like,
yeah, you noticed this
poem of Claudia Rankine
is really political.
And I'm like, but Claudia Rankine
always been Claudia Rankine.
And it's just, how do you approach
the breadth and the length of the work?
And I think it becomes
productive both ways.
I tend to not care what white
people think about my work.
Like that's not even
what I'm concerned about,
about how people are
productive in that matter.
I'm concerned about the people who I know
who think that my Kamala Harris piece
was supposed to say what
they wanted it to say.
Who feel like, Oh yeah,
I've read your piece,
and what I just don't understand this.
You don't know the Kamala Harris is a cop,
you know who wants slogans from me.
And that's why I've resisted.
I've resisted because man, look,
I shouldn't even tell this story.
I'm gonna tell it.
- Hold on,
go ahead, go ahead 'cause
you gonna do it anyway.
- I get invited to this gig here at Yale.
I'm some such and such.
And I'm having lunch with the folks
and they say, first story is like,
it was so brave of you and your book
to admit that you sexually
assaulted somebody.
I was like, Oh shit, what book?
And I knew the poem
they were talking about.
And when I wrote the poem,
the people who published
the poem the first time
as a "Crown" the (indistinct) "Felon".
they called me, and they were like,
"Do you know, in this book
you admit to raping somebody?"
And I was like,
I'm absolutely certain that
I didn't admit to doing it
because I've never done it.
And I could have told them,
I'm absolutely certain that
I didn't admit to doing that
because I feel like
that's the worst thing on
this planet you could do
given the experience
of women in my family.
But I didn't want to go that route.
And I only say it now
because I've written a piece
and it's out there, but
this person was trying to,
they needed to connect to poetry,
not to something that was deeper,
not to something that was raised in
the same kind of questions
or the right white artists
that they teach in a classroom.
They needed to connect it to me.
And it was no reason
for them to have that
need to connect it to me.
I don't read Emily Dickinson
and wonder if she did
the things that she did
and I just don't read poetry that way.
And I know that I've
been constantly taught
that you weren't supposed
to read literature that way.
But it's a strange thing
in which the writing
of like black Raiders gets
reduced wholly to the personal,
and it has no imaginative force.
This is what they tell you,
"I wish I lived the kind of life you live
"so that I could write like you."
You don't fucking wish
you lived the life I lived
and you can live the life I live
and still can't write like me.
But that is not what they say to Ashbury.
I've never heard somebody say,
"Asbury is just the profound
suffering you've experienced
"allows you to be a great artist."
That is not the way we approach white art.
And I feel like it's not
just like the white community
or the white world or a
white critics would do that.
I feel like unfortunately,
is many people who want
you to be a jukebox
and they choose the songs
that they want you to sing
and they don't read
the work as expansively
to allow permission for other things
to exist within that work.
They don't say, why does
that poem have a speaker
who says what that last poem says?
'Cause that's not important.
What's important is how
they could characterize me.
And they were dead wrong.
And I'ma start saying that
every time I meet a white writer,
I'ma take the most absurd thing
that has been written in a book and say,
"I can't believe
"that you feel that
way about your mother."
It's just sort of absurdity,
things that I would never
imagine doing that people do.
- First of all,
you know what they said about Ashbury?
They said, "We don't know what the fuck
"you're writing about."
They trashed his early books
because they were so obscure.
And part of the reason
they were so obscure
is because he was at Yale and he was gay
and he couldn't admit
and write from that positionality.
He had to create a kind
of vague subjectivity
that could move through those poems.
But that's another day
and another conversation.
What about you Titus?
- I think it's interesting
'cause there is difference
because I'm making images,
I'm making pictures, words and pictures
are very, very, very different.
And so I make images
which requires not requires
that's the wrong word,
compels people to want words.
And sometimes you are making images
because you're trying to
visualize something and ineffable.
Something that doesn't have words.
I start for me.
I explore all kinds of ideas, of course,
but I do start from a place of like,
where do I connect to the story?
Whether it's like
directly autobiographical
is a different thing.
But for me it's like,
how do I connect to the story?
And that's something I think about a lot.
The other thing is,
right now everybody wants to talk
about black artist having a moment.
And it's funny to me,
some black artists that they're
talking about having moments
have been here for like 50 years,
but they're now having a moment.
I'm not really interested in the...
I'm not interested in
trying to make work...
Let me put it this way.
The revolution I'm fighting for
is not one where everybody
makes the same work
as Kerry James Marshall.
His work as amazing,
but that sort of figurative work
that speaks directly about
the reality of black life
is not what I'm fighting for
or even people making
the work that I make.
As I think about this in
the context of Next Haven.
What I'm interested in is like the freedom
to make whatever you wanna make.
What you talked about Claudia
was this idea that black folks
not being able to make
something that feels universal.
That's really what it comes down to.
If Donald Judd can make a black square
and explore minimalism in that way,
I think our folks should be
able to do the exact same thing.
I know that in my work is
going to continue to evolve.
And so I'm gonna do all
kinds of different things,
but that is actually
the freedom that I want
is just that ability to explore
whether it's abstraction,
minimalism, figurative,
whatever it may be.
- That brings me to the practice.
'Cause I'm really interested
in the pleading freedoms process
and Rauschenberg, Robert Rauschenberg,
he erased de Kooning's drawings in 1953.
And just for John's referred
to the idea of a racial
as additive subtractions.
And I really love that term
we saw in the initial images,
and I guess I can see
them behind you Dwayne,
that sense of going back into the archives
and erasing in order to add,
in order to extend the
cultural readability
of the document.
So I'm wondering if you could speak
why both of you have gone in the direction
of redactions in a racial,
how you think about it
when you are doing it,
whether it's painting, the
white washing the painting
or using tar to cover
the phase or to redact
as you did in those, in
those pieces behind you.
- Yeah, I was thinking about,
first, I was thinking
about Percival Everett,
great novel eraser.
And one of the things that he does is,
he creates this character
that is writing a fictation novel.
He's like a judge for a big award.
And he's frustrated with the way
in which people think about
the awards to come through.
So he quickly pins of a
fake novel about black life
and what he does,
I think as a racist order to complexity
out of black life within that novel
and he expects it to flop,
but then it ends up winning
the prize that he's judging
and it ends up being
like wildly successful,
more so than anything he's ever written.
And so I tend to think of
redaction beyond a racial
because I think about a racial.
I think about a racial as the way in which
you could cripple the
understanding of a subject
by thinning it out to
justice as a stereotype.
And I think the law as a whole,
when you take that whole legal document,
I think so often a law
as a whole does something
to like flush great out understanding
of really complex issues
with all of the words they get added.
So I like the notion of
subtraction as addition,
because I was trying to
think of sort of independent
and related to the work that me insight
as we're thinking about, really.
I was just trying to understand the law
in such a way that I could
convey it to my folks.
And I thought, what if I redacted,
what if I just argued
that a lot of this stuff doesn't matter?
And I wasn't trying to do this in a way
to transform the text
to say something else,
but I was trying to do what
personal ever did, but flip it,
Instead of writing the novel
that makes you aware of
all of the disingenuous ways we view life,
what if I got rid of
all the illegal leaves
to make you aware of what's
really at stake in these cases?
And what was more troubling to me
is how many pages I could get rid of.
I would start with 70
pages and end up with 10,
and I would start with 70
pages and ended up with eight.
But the beauty of it was...
And part of this wasn't just me,
it was the lawyers who wrote these briefs,
they thought it was really important
to find a way to bring
to life the men and women
who were suffered under
the system of money bail,
or really under the system
of incarcerated people
'cause they were too poor to pay.
If I wanted to summarize it in a sentence,
whether you're talking
about traffic tickets
or bail or minor fines or fees.
And it's cool though
'cause there's a lawyer,
nobody understands
the bandwidth of the
stuff I do with my family,
but they understand things like freedom.
And I think these pieces allow
me to sort of tell a story
in such a way that my folks would get it.
- Thank you, Titus?
- I was interested in
redaction as Mark Macon.
One of the things that
Dwayne and I talked about
when we started working on this project
is how do we collaborate on
something that doesn't diminish
either the image or the text.
And so usually when
you have collaborations
with art and texts,
sometimes one of those
things becomes the superior.
And we wanted that not to happen.
So the redaction itself,
the process had to be,
it had to be brush marks.
It had to be a part of
the, the work itself,
the painting itself.
And so redaction just became
the go-to language for us
because it was a part of what we were
or what I have been doing for a long time.
redaction was for me in the painting
you've been thinking
about the pain behind me.
It's a way of focusing my perspective,
focusing my attention,
given myself the opportunity
to move some other things in
the composition to the side
while I explore a quiet idea
that hasn't really had the opportunity
to have the volume turned up on it.
So in some ways, redacting
is the opportunity
to turn the volume up
on other parts of the composition.
- Titus if the collaboration
caused you do wish
to equalize image text
inside these pieces,
how is that different
from when you're working
on your own with the white
washing or the cutouts?
- I have to trust,
I have to trust
that the redaction,
that sort of redaction that
is dependent on the content
of the poem that Duane is making
is still a statically function.
What we found is, it's all these words.
It was never a problem,
we were redacting things.
So the process of making these pieces...
Dwayne, can you possibly share your screen
and share that image
of the two larger redaction pieces?
So Dwayne takes the text
and the legal document,
and then he redacts it down.
- But you got to say too though.
'Cause cause part of it is like,
it don't work if you get a print
and you have to read the next print
to understand the content.
So almost had to make it like a haiku.
Like it's a sequence, but
each one has to stand alone.
So if I was to read this one,
when you get to $25 per
day cleaning a city,
scrub the feces and
blood from jail floors.
Like that's a wrap and we
could go to the next thing,
but that's a complete idea in itself.
Because again, it has to be
some kind of literal integrity
with the words on a page
and the actual page itself.
- Yeah, but in each of these pieces,
each piece is actually four pieces.
There's a portrait
that I etched onto the
panel and then print
then a second portrait
that etched and print.
Then we silk screen the text
and then we silk screen the redaction.
And so we're seeing each layer
of this individual piece come together.
And after looking at it again and again,
what we realized was the deconstruction
was interesting in itself.
So we started doing these pieces
where we were showing
the individual layers
because it helped you understand,
it helps you understand
how the work functions
when they're all together.
We tried initially doing some redactions
where it was more a digital redaction
and we realized very quickly
that the hand was necessary.
And so Dwayne redacted each
one of these lines by hand.
It's subtle but it makes a huge difference
that those lines are not
precise, that they are handmade.
They angle slightly, they
wave, they undo undulate,
that's all really important.
So again, it allowed us,
it allows the viewer, it
allows me as a first viewer
to move back and forth between
the faces and the redaction
as marks and the texts
all sort of imbalanced with one another.
- I also liked the fact
that from the get go,
it suggests a kind of partial justice
that the act of redaction means that
we never bringing the
full force of the text
to the plaintiff or to
the moment in a way.
But I understand also
that there were other
ways of thinking about it.
Do either of you think about
counter narratives as a strategy
for the work that the...
Dwayne, you said you don't
care what white people think
or it's not a frame
you're working against.
But are you thinking as,
it's 2020, we're making work all of us.
And this is also true I
think for those people
who are doing academic work.
That there is a way in
which a thing has been told,
a story has been told,
a picture has been set,
and then there's another way to do it.
And I feel like the choices
that both of you are making
are actually critically engage to disrupt
and prevent certain kinds of readings
that here to for determined
the narratives around certain subjects.
- Maybe I think a more correct way
I could have put my statement
is that I can't what everybody thinks,
but I'm not concerned
with trying to perform
for a particular audience
at a particular time.
And so it's almost as if
the first poem I mentioned
"House of Unending".
It's almost as if that poem,
which has some moments
that can be read as literally about me,
but also has moments
that can be obviously
read it's not about me.
Almost as if that poem sets up a narrative
that they're not gonna engage and get at
with the Kamala Harris' piece.
Even though when I write
"House of Unending",
I'm not even thinking about
the Kamala Harris piece.
So yeah, maybe that's true
but I just don't think that...
First of all, I think as a poet,
the one beauty of poetry
is that any collection
is filled with narratives
and counter narratives.
But I think the other beauty of the poem
is that unlike memoir
is that I could like bring my imagination
to explore and explore the sorta tension
between a narrative and
a counter narrative.
And to be quite frank often,
I'm not certain where I'm positioned
within that conversation.
And I kinda think,
and this is the difference
between me being an artist
and me being an activist
is when I'm representing
somebody on parole.
You got murders and we're going to work
to get you out of prison.
And this is how we going
to tell this story,
and this is who you are.
And yeah, I'm honest about it.
I think that they are...
I believe in them.
But if I didn't believe in
them, my narrative is set.
And I think as an artist,
my intentions don't have to drive
what people take from the work.
It's a certain kind of freedom
and which I could do my thing
and let it live in a world in a way
that's not solely driven
by what I want audience's response to be.
And that's quite unlike I think
the work I do when I
represent people in parole,
and I think that's like
closer to activism demo art.
'Cause when I represent you,
I know what we want the outcome to be.
And I know when I failed.
The only time I feel as an artist,
it's like when my son was like,
"Yeah, you can't say that."
I'm like, "Huh?"
He's like, "Yeah, you know
that line right there,
"where you called yourself
a felon on like that.
"I don't think that's true."
Like that's when I feel as an artist
because somebody who I
wasn't even thinking about it
as my audience has like
cut into my thinking
in a way that makes me feel like,
yeah, I could have thought better.
And that's the failure of an artist.
I think at least that's
my failure of artists.
When I find that, like,
I could've thought better
in my art and I didn't.
Although I kept my line
'cause I ain't gonna let
no nine-year-old edit me.
I'm just not with it.
- I wanna throw this in there too.
I wanna get to the counter
narrative in a second,
but this is something that
Dwayne and I think about a lot.
We're working on this
other project together,
this film project, and
a couple of weeks ago,
Dwayne was in the New York
Times for a piece that he did,
and I was in the New York
Times for a piece that we did.
Those pieces were reviewed
by different people,
but who doesn't get to review our work.
Our work generally is not
reviewed by our mothers
and the people that
they sort of represent.
And so what we did was
we actually had our mothers
interview each other.
That's to me, my mother's
thought on my work
is sort of symbolic
of like my community's thought
on my work in that way.
That's something that I think about like,
I think way more about
what you and Dwayne think about my work
than I think about what the New York Times
or whoever's reviewing my
work says about our work.
I'm fine with them hating everything I do.
I'm not fine with y'all
hating everything I do
because you know my intentions,
you know me,
you know what I'm trying
to get at in this thing.
If I fail on that stage,
that's a whole different kind of calculus.
So I am looking at the counter narrative.
That is something that I'm interested in,
but I'm interested in it in the context
of me as the first audience,
how do I wanna see it?
And that evolved in me
because I had to learn in graduate school
that the professors critiqued
what I was doing quite a bit.
That's the nature of
the MFA program at Yale.
And I didn't have a whole lot of allies
when I started cutting
holes and paintings.
I didn't have a whole lot of allies
when I started Washington paintings.
Those same professors now
are very interested in what I'm doing,
but at the time that's not it.
So I had to figure out
whether I wanted it or not,
whether it felt right to
me or not knowing that
they may never get it.
When I'm saying like,
when I sort of pushed back on being
a sort of activist,
that's kind of where
some of that comes from,
because I feel like it's necessary
for me to prioritize my
conception of the piece,
my understanding of the piece
before it goes off into the world.
- You know what's crazy though.
And I should admit this,
is I did a whole lot of
work too saying artists
should work more with
activist organizations
and non-profit organizations
and did some work raising money
and trying to build those connections
between those organizations or artists.
But my point wasn't to turn
to artists into activist.
My point was they acknowledged
that we all live in this community,
and that I do think that
the work of activists
and the work of government officials
would just be much better
if it was more deeply engaged with art.
And I do believe that you could do that
without becoming propaganda for a machine.
And I think that some
places across the country
have begun to think about that.
But you know, it's interesting,
you talk to public
defenders and they be like
a lesson before dying.
Who is dead.
And it's like, Oh, how do
we really do this work?
And how do we really feel a
deep connection to the people
who deeply do this work when
they literally sometimes
will only support things
that you do and say
that follows the company
line that they want to push.
I got friends who were like,
we were colleagues, we worked together
and that sort of response
to my Time's piece.
And I was like, all right,
we aren't actually friends,
we aren't actually colleagues.
What you wanted was,
you wanted a puppet.
And because I wouldn't refer it back
to the things that you
were whispering in my ear,
you don't wanna support the piece.
You not retweeted it to your audience,
you're not engaging with it.
And I get it, I'm not mad,
but now I recognize that
you're a part of the problem.
Because as soon as my community's justice
is not in your interests,
then my community's justice
won't be on your agenda.
And I think that that's one
of the things that I resist.
Although I worked really
hard to get people to care.
- Let me add one piece to that,
this political conversation,
like just recognizing that
it's all gonna be
political in some and that.
I think that part of the reason why
I also pushed back on this idea
of being a political artist
is because I don't want the work
to not be understood formally as well.
You are a great poet
not simply because of what you talk about,
but the way you talk
about what you talk about,
how you do it,
the formal structures that you manipulate
and use and change and alter,
the rules that you use and
the rules that you break.
When we talk about political art,
the formal part of the art
goes out of the conversation.
It's like, no, you didn't spend
20 years learning your craft
and trying to figure this out
and creating a language
that's functional for you.
What it becomes is like a
conversation about the politics.
And I know, going back to what Dwayne said
about like first person
writing in the first person,
I know that there are some times
where like, you'll look
at a piece and you'll go,
this is an amazing piece,
I'm not sure if it fits the politics
but this is an amazing piece.
And this is something we struggle with
when we look at art history itself.
There are plenty of pieces that we look at
and we go, politically, this is off.
This is really off.
And at the same time,
I'm struggling because I recognize
that that is masterfully executed.
I think for me,
I wanna live in that tension.
I want there to be this difficult place.
I don't wanna just hold on to one yes,
Titus Kaphar a political artists
or no Titus Kaphar completely formalist.
I want to live in some
place in the middle.
- That is a great place
to open up the discussion.
We are at four o'clock and I
see no questions in my chat.
Perhaps there's a private check Crystal
that I'm supposed to go to,
but in the chat function
there are no questions.
- The people haven't
put in their questions,
but this is the moment for them to start.
They can say that a question
to you in the private chat,
that would be great.
But they will start doing that now.
- While we wait for that to happen,
maybe I can ask this one last question,
because by talking about
both of you as artists,
important artists, contemporary artists
who engage issues of our time,
it's not really an attempt
to call you political artists.
It's a way of saying,
it's what is great about the work,
is that it does not shy away
from the realities of our time
and those realities engage
many of the political hot topics of now.
So it's just part of
what the entire picture
of the life's work is.
But I understand that we're
constantly in that fight
not to have that word
political engagement reduce the work
and its achievements and it's excellence
and craft and all of that.
- But I would no doubt in a minute
be the like poet in
residence at the national
for Sherrilyn Ifill.
I would like no doubt be
like if Bryan Stevenson
was like, look, man,
we needed a suite of poems
like Robyn Hayden did
when he did that suite of seven poems
called "Burning Spear".
Man I'm hip to that.
And I wanna commission you
to do something like that.
So I guess what I mean
is this is a kind of superficial
engagement with the work.
I haven't been writing
the same poem since 1996,
but I've had the same obsession since 1996
because when they take a 16 year old
and put them in solitary confinement
for 10 days without giving them a bath,
it tends to stay on your
mind for a long time.
So I've had the same political obsessions
'cause when you know men who
got sentenced into life at 15,
and they stay your friends when you're 40,
those become your obsessions.
But I think one of the things
I just wanna make clear about is,
I'm not interested
in a redactive
characterization of my work.
If we wanna have a real back and forth
about what it means to connect
the things that are right
to the struggle,
to end the over-incarceration
of the people in this country,
if we wanna connect to
things that are right
to achieve in social justice
among what school spectrums.
That I'm really deeply invested in that.
But what happens, I
think is a lot of times
people just want a superficial engagement.
You can turn on a news and you will not...
I won't turn on the news
and see Claudia Rankine
in the middle of the
discussion about addresses.
Even something as basic
as microaggressions
and people will like name drop your book
and they will be like,
and you will say
we having this conversation
about Michael Brown.
We've been talking about this
for a long time for decades.
And my work wasn't in the
center of that conversation
because the people who were
doing social justice work shows
not to have it in a center compensation,
or maybe not the people
doing social justice work,
but just our inclination as a country.
And so I guess what I mean is
I don't wanna be the like step...
I don't stepchildren.
I don't wanna use that metaphor.
I don't wanna be like the handmade,
but if you say handmade,
and that sounds really scary right now.
I don't wanna be that off thing.
I wanna be an integral part
of the actual work that's going on
in a way that I feel like,
grapes of wrath was.
In a way that I feel like
other texts in the past,
like really existed as like a
fundamental part of the work
that was being,
and maybe I'm just being idealist
and maybe they felt the same way I feel,
but I sort of just feel like,
I feel like I'm not,
I feel like I'm always embarrassed
about how little lawyers
I know know about...
Your work was the first
work that somebody was like,
"Yoh Dwayne have you
read this book "Citizen"?
And I'm laughing, I'm like, all right,
I'm glad you reading "Citizen",
but what made it profound was
that was like the first time
that people in law school was
carrying around poetry books.
I was thinking about literature,
I was thinking about...
And Titus' work is one
of the first times folks
is like, yeah, man, this guy,
poets that we know is like,
you notice guy Titus Kaphar.
And as being a part of the
landscape of the conversation.
But I guess I just want
not to be an afterthought.
And so that's why I want to claim that.
- (indistinct) and then
move to the question.
I was in Wyoming getting on
one of those little planes
that terrify everybody.
And this guy said to me, he's a poet.
So it's not totally out of
the blue, but he said to me,
"Have you heard of this
guy, Dwayne Betts?"
And this was before, this was like,
I think even before your
first book came out.
I think you shouldn't underestimate
the power of poetry out in the world.
- Do sounds like a genius though.
He sounds like an exceptional human being.
- Yeah, but he is.
Jenny Tang wants to know.
"I wanted to ask about their
investments both of you
"in portraiture and relation
of portraits to history
"and subject hood and subjectivity."
And so I guess it's both about
the use of the first person.
That would be another
way of thinking about it,
but you want to start Titus?
- My favorite historical
work is portraiture.
Like I go to at first
when I'm at the museum,
but you end up seeing,
at least I ended up seeing people
who don't really look like me
and we're all arrogant to some degree,
and we're all looking
for ourselves and images.
And I wanted to understand
how to paint my skin.
And so usually as an artist,
what they tell you is
to go to the masters.
And that's how you're supposed to learn
is to go to the masters.
But I recognize that the
masters hadn't explored
on what I was trying to explore
and that the occasions
where there were
portraits of black people,
there were more caricatures
than they were portraits.
If you were painting someone who loved
you wouldn't have painted them like that.
And that was my experience
of looking at portraits
in the museum.
I spend a lot of time still thinking about
the representation of people,
not as a traditional portrait.
I have one behind me,
which is a character study,
which is the big version of the small one
that's in your spot body accurate.
I also make portraiture where
you don't see the face at all,
where you may just see this silver wet
and it's a way of addressing
what wasn't there,
what you didn't see,
but it's still acknowledging
that there was a black presence,
even though I don't have the features
to be able to articulate that.
There are no existing
or historical records
or details about those individuals.
And therefore there's no way for me
to like, put that down on canvas.
Sometimes what that looks like
is just a completely tarred out face
or a silhouette of an individual
that stands in for
someone I wish I did know.
- I'm just gonna add Sarah Lewis's work
around Frederick Douglas
and how he was the most photographed men
of the 19th century.
And that his intention really was
to put images of black
people, men out there
using his own image,
but just to proliferate, just do it
so that when you close your eyes
and you think what is
a black guy look like?
It turns out he looks
like Frederick Douglas.
So in a way that impulse to shift away
from those images of daguerreotypes
of enslaved people into a different image
becomes the ones you see
walking in the street
in (indistinct) becomes a...
I'm gonna do the next question,
and then Dwayne, you can take that
and then we'll just switch back and forth
so we can cover as many
questions as possible.
This one, so Sarah,
I'm gonna skip your
question and go to Jason's.
"There are several,
"what seemed to me
problematic dichotomies here
"on the one hand Mr.
Betts draws a dichotomy
"between the personal and the political,
"and the personal can be very political,
"but I wanna ask Mr. Kaphar
about a dichotomy he drew
"which also seems to me to be real,
"but also misleading between
the formal properties of art
"and its excellence as political.
"One of the ways in which Mr.
Kaphar's work is outstanding
"is that the political message
"is not didactic and overbearing.
"It seems to me that here it's not just
"that the formal excellence,
"it's not just about
the formal excellence,"
it's going off the screen,
"plus an important political message.
"The fact that his art is
not didactically political
"has something to do with
an aesthetic properties
"over and above the formal work.
"Political excellence in arts
"is not just having a good message.
"I'm wondering if he would speak
to this aspect of the work,
"how the aesthetics and the political
"combined to make a political
message, not didactic."
Dwayne, if you started with thinking
a little bit about the
personal and political again,
and then we moved
to Titus' separation of
those two things as well.
- But I think even a
separation counts for my work.
You read my poems, you got blank verse,
you have guzzles, you have
sestinas, you have calzones,
you have a crown of sonnets.
you got a lot of formal
attention to like...
Arguably I'm like a legit formless,
you know what I mean?
I'm like, arguably,
one might say that I
favor form more than that.
I think though, thinking
about the personal
and the political,
and I think about the way
that art is perceived,
I guess one of the distinctions
I'm just trying to draw
is between, like I
frequently just don't know
what I'm gonna say when I go to the page,
and I'm just trying to
draw that distinction.
I write, even Kamala Harris piece,
I don't know what I'm gonna
say when I go to the page
and a process of producing art
is the one relying on some of
the formal skills I have
to push me to a truth
that I didn't have when I started.
And I think too to try to reveal something
about the thing that I'm writing about
that astonishes me.
So I guess my, I don't
know if the dichotomy
is a real dichotomy on that,
except I'm trying to distinguish between,
I think like gossip and gospel.
And I think gossip
is what you trade with
friends on street corners
and gospel is when you hear a story
from a friend on a street corner,
and you have to say it again,
and you have to say it again
in a meaningful saying that is
because you think it just makes
the world feel a bit better
by having told that story again.
I like to believe that the
poacher rate does that,
but I also like to
believe that it does that
because I don't know what
I'm gonna say going in.
I think what you're saying
that is incredibly important,
and as a fellow poet, I totally
totally agree with this,
is that the creation of art
really doesn't have intention in it.
And that's what makes it creation,
that the act of creation
is happening in the making of the thing.
And intention has to do
with having an agenda,
which is how we think
about political action
and acting on that agenda
towards that agenda.
That's why they say, like my
agenda here is women's choice.
And then they go and do
the many different ways,
approach that issue in
those different ways.
What about you Titus?
What are you thinking about-
- I think the reason the
person sees the dichotomy
is 'cause that's what I'm trying to say.
I'm trying to say that
I'm trying to do both.
I'm trying to exist in both.
And as soon as you look
at something of mine
and you think of it as a
political piece, stop doing that
and think of it as a formal piece,
then stop doing that,
and then think of it as a political piece.
I wanna be bouncing back
and forth between us.
I don't want you to feel comfortable
calling me a political artist,
and I don't want you to feel comfortable
calling me a formal artist.
I want you to exist in
both of those space.
It's difficult for us to hold
these two different ideas
in our hands at the same time,
but I'm asking you to do that.
'Cause that's the way
I approach your work.
And it does have to do
with this idea of process
that if I'm in the studio,
when I'm making a painting,
but in this painting,
what I politically believe
is not highlighted,
but formally the thing is blowing my mind,
the painting is done.
And so I have to wrestle
in myself with what to do
with this other sort of political stuff
that's like not working,
but I have to sit with it.
Because what I've learned from my process
is what Dwayne is saying,
half the time I don't know.
I just don't.
The first time I balled up a painting,
I had no idea what I was doing.
No clue at all.
It made no sense to me.
I just knew I had to do it, period.
And then I balled up the painting
and looked at it and went,
I don't know what the fuck this is.
Like, I don't even know
what I'm supposed to be doing with this.
And then I came back a week
later and saw the same thing
and went, Oh my God, there it is.
So I cannot be the kind of artist
that puts arbitrary restrictions
on my creative process
in order to fit some political agenda,
because I would diminish
myself as the creator
that I'm attempting to be.
I'm still who I am.
I still, the personal is political
as we talked about before,
I still hold the spiritual
ideas that I hold.
I still believe the things that I believe,
and that is going to find
its way into the work.
And I trust that.
I trust that.
And to the degree that there
is like internal conflict
in the work, I believe that
that's a valuable thing.
Like there is, we are,
we are conflicted people.
And if my work doesn't reflect
some kind of internal conflict,
then I'm not reflecting myself.
- So then in a way
and I agree with this,
the word artist is a verb
and it is constantly influx.
I don't really have the same
thing about how political work,
because I feel like what I'm...
There's no way to pull out
the politics from the reality
or from the life.
You just cannot.
It's like saying I can
put it on at five o'clock
and take it off at three o'clock.
I cannot, I cannot,
especially not as a black woman, I cannot.
There's no way for me to
go to the page and work
without all of that being in the flux
of the creative process of the activity
of the verbness of the word artists,
I would say that.
- I wonder if there is a
parallel in the visual art world
and poetry world.
I don't know.
But my experience at Yale
was zero conversation
about the political aspect
of what I was doing,
zero conversation about
the social implications
of what I was doing.
And then once in a while,
someone from another department
would come in and try to have
a conversation about that
in our critiques.
And it would be very clear
that the room was not prepared
for that conversation.
And so what ends up
happening is there is a...
And I'm not saying that this
is good, by the way, I'm just-
- No, no, no, no, no.
- There is a way in
which visual arts can...
People will surely review the thing
based on it's like formal aspects
in the conversation that's had,
this is a conversation with
abstract expressionism,
and you're thinking about the cacooning.
And you're thinking about...
All of these things,
we can have a very, very
long conversation about that.
And not one time,
not one time talk about
the black character,
or we can have the opposite conversation
where we only talk about
the fact that there's a
black character there,
and we don't talk about
the fact that yes, in
fact, I am in conversation
with the cacooning.
I am having a conversation
about abstract expressionism-
- Poets do that all the time.
- Pardon.
- But I think we're both
what we're talking about.
I think when you say that.
When you talk about the
historian, the art historians,
the world of critique,
we're talking about standards put in place
by white people who have decided
that as much as the work
looks like their work,
that's how good it,
and that's how excellence
is maintained and created.
And so to have to refer to black people
as a political force or as a human being,
that's a whole nother...
So you can't really...
There's a great essay
which might be of interest to
both of you by Denise morale.
She talks about Manet's Olympia
and how all of the critical
work done up until now
gave a sentence to the
black woman in the painting.
It said the black woman in
the painting and the cat
have no significance, but if you...
And then she went back and
looked at Manet's archives,
he painted three paintings
of that black woman.
He was interested in her
role in Paris at that time.
But white artistsans
in their myopic centering of whiteness
dismissed even his intention,
even Manet's intention.
- Yeah, I've read, I listened,
I watched the lecture.
- (indistinct)
- Her book is...
I didn't read the book yet,
but it looks fascinating.
And I caught the lecture
that she gave about it.
- But I'm gonna end
with the last question.
Sarah Smith, "I would
love to know more about
"what Titus mentioned
"was the difference between how audiences
"approach works of art.
"Could they both say more
about the expectations
"that audiences bring to visual art
"versus the written word?"
Separate question, "How do
audiences take into account
"the breadth and length
of the artistic process
"while also accounting for the ways
"that the artists writer
changes over time?"
So questions about-
- Audience.
- Audience and also the breadth
of the uber of the artists.
- I think the first question
we've been talking about
the whole time really.
- I think it's different
expectation though
for painters and poets, I think.
- I mean, don't neither one
of us have our audience.
This is like the reality of it,
we having this conversation-
- I think we planned I think
the poets had no audience.
- No painters ain't got
no audience, this is real.
One of the things is like,
to figure out how to have
people have art in their homes
and think about art.
And that's what made me
insight is doing a book
for the redaction 'cause we like,
we want the book in people's houses
so that it's a part...
Remember what "Crowns"
came out about 2005, 2006.
And it had a companion book
that was about black women heads.
And I was working at a
bookstore during that time
and it was flying off the shelf.
We didn't have any art
books in a bookstore.
But that book was flying off the shelves
'cause people in the community
was really interested
in this book about heads.
I think Oprah might've
featured it or something.
But I think the reality is
that like we both struggle,
we have in a real audience.
It's just that we got
to do the Wu Tang thing
where we just produce one copy of our book
and sell it for 15 grand.
We satisfied with this 1000
print run, 2000 print run.
I think we, we got to do bigger.
But the last thing I'll
say about audience though,
which is, I think is
part of what me and Titus
have been doing with this
project and thinking about,
as we produce this book
and thinking about making it
accessible to a larger audience
and having Pleading Freedoms
and a neighborhood in New Haven
where art usually doesn't exist
is bringing it more to the people.
And for poetry,
I think for me my challenge is,
how do I make sure I give a good show?
And then how do I make that show exist
in spaces that could like have
more people come to see it?
And that is like a real challenge for me
is to do something that's enjoyable.
And so I turned felon
and two into a solo show
with the intention of saying,
I'm gonna be on Broadway,
how do you produce a piece
that like demands an audience.
Somebody in a season,
like somebody flexing in the chat room,
like I have a copy of "Crowns",
and that's what I'm talking about,
where you were like that book exists
the way it was on the bookshelves
like it was a best seller.
And so anyway, I want my poetry to live
and communicate to the
audience in that way.
And I know I didn't exactly
answer the question,
but I think
I wanna cut through this
discussion of audience and say,
what is the product that I produced,
the art that I produce,
what kind of audience does it demand?
And my continued challenge as artists
is to make a demand a bigger
and a broader audience
so that they actually
can be a part of the political landscape
and the political conversation
in a way that it might just be nipping
at the outskirts right now.
- Junior and Sandra both
have a copy of "Crown".
So I think you're speaking.
- Audiences is a weird thing.
We're talking about the schools of thought
that review our work.
Let's be honest,
I'm trained in a very European tradition
of making paintings.
And even though I push
against it in some ways,
and people understand it
or don't understand it,
faculty understand that or
don't understand that back then.
That that is that, that is that language.
And so I'm like trying to
take that and make it my own
and do what I wanna do with it.
But the audience question
is complicated for me now,
because there's one way where I could say
the audience of my paintings
are the people who buy my paintings.
No, no, not anymore.
That can't be it.
Because I come from that
tradition where as painters
we're literally taught,
it's weird 'cause this is contradiction.
We're taught that you're
not supposed to be thinking
about the audience.
You're not supposed to
be thinking about that.
You're supposed to be thinking about you
and like how you think about the piece
and how you come to the peace,
is different from like theater
where you're always
thinking about the audience
and how like the audience
is going to receive
and think about a piece.
Where are you gonna be on the Stage
in relationship to where
the audience is gonna be
like, that's a part of
the art form itself.
I now have to find different ways
to get to my audience.
First audience is me, always.
I'm always my first audience.
I'm never gonna make a thing
that the rest of the world
thinks is amazing, but I hate it.
I'm just not willing
to put stuff out in the world like that.
It doesn't matter to me what
everybody else thinks about.
I'm working on finding
ways to get after myself
as a first audience,
get to this other, my folks
like my folks to see it
because the work is now at a place
where I'm happy to have the
success that I'm having,
but it means there is a
limited number of people
who are living with my work now.
And those-
- I will accept the piece though.
If you want to expand that limited number
- (indistinct) stop playing.
- (indistinct)
- We have to find ways,
I have to find ways to reconnect.
And so what do we do?
We do these prints, we do these books.
I'm constantly asked to do
these talks and lectures.
And honestly, I evaluate
whether I do a talk in lecture
based on the access of the
people who asked me to do it.
If you have a lot of access,
I'm likely to say no,
if you don't have access,
I'm likely to say yes,
because like those often
are the communities
that at very least reflect my experience
which is where my quote
audience comes from.
Even when thinking about myself.
What would I have thought
about this growing up
where I grew up 30, 40 years ago?
Like what would have
might have experience,
like we said before,
what does mom think about this?
What does mom..
Like my mother's reaction
to Dwayne's piece,
that was powerful.
Way, way more impacting
than reading Roberta
Smith review of my work.
Way, way, way more of that.
- I think that's a
powerful note to end on.
And I think Claudia.
- I have all these
questions I didn't ask him
because you brought up refer to spit
- (indistinct)
- He called your work conceptual objects.
How did you feel about that?
- Who did? Me?
- No, Roberta Smith.
- She called them conceptual objects.
- I think because they have cutouts.
As I was thinking about
that phrase, I thought,
I wonder what Titus is
thinking about that.
- Because I know the
language of art review.
I'm gonna accept the compliment
she was trying to give me, how's that?
I know what her intention was
and we don't have to rehearse this
but what I will say is that
it does go back to this idea
of formal versus political.
It goes back to that.
She's elevating it in her mind,
in her mind, that's what's happening.
So I'll accept that compliment.
- Because of the phrase brought
to me like a David Hammons
and you're work and David
Hammond seems so different to me.
That's why I was curious what you thought.
But thank you both, thank you both.
- Thank you, this was cool.
It's actually important.
I do think one of the reasons
why I was excited about doing this
is 'cause it was the three of us,
and I think about how we
create historical records
and how historical records from the past.
You read a letter from Richard
Wright to Gwendolyn Brooks
and he's like, man.
Richard Wright is like
talking about the Guggenheim
and you think it just means something
to be a part a conversation
between the two of them.
And it means a lot to be
a part of a conversation
with the two of you.
- Thank you Dwayne.
- And it's amazing to be able
to witness that conversation.
So I wanna thank you all three
for agreeing to do it and
doing it so beautifully.
And I know we're in this Zoom world,
but I do like to take
a moment to ask people
to unmute and to actually clap,
because I think we need
to applaud you your work
and this conversation.
(participants clapping)